this book what's incredible about it is
your honesty you know it takes it takes
guts to just you you're very open in
this book yeah I'm gonna be single
forever yeah well you say you're honest
about many things including you admit
openly that you've had a lot of trouble
choosing men yeah in your life my
Pickers off yeah I have this condition
called codependence and in for me it
manifested in I couldn't see red flags
in a man I think my brain would
immediately turn a negative like into a
positive like I'd meet a guy and I'd be
like oh he's married was not afraid of
commitment could turn a nice you're sure
he doesn't have a driver's license
because he got a DUI loves the
environment he has no Carbon football
extend narcissists and actors I was
making bad choices
yeah and so you you're in a good
relationship now I am I'm in a good
relation
yeah you either find a husband or you
get murdered there's like no in-between
right what did you both love you were
married I kind of realized my definition
of love is like being willing to die for
someone that you yourself want to kill
yeah fantastic so you're in a what is
different about this guy that then all
the other guys what does it really make
some sets him apart well I am not
allowing him to see my stand-up comedy
okay
these are very good stand-up why would
you not want to see you that's very nice
well I would you want you know oh yeah
is it's an expression of you though
wouldn't you want to share that with
them er I think some things are better
kept secret I don't look at his porn he
doesn't watch my stand-up it's a very
good
I think you should watch his porn
together here's your make living a
living at stand-up does he make a living
have a Warren bougie wait where'd you
meet on its ground that's not a dating
yeah yeah that's like no I just saw
pictures thrown in the internet so I
went in the flounder location what I
didn't realize people could just meet
that way they did I I don't think that's
legal
yeah he didn't say whether or not he
stole the baby that could mean anything
you